so knowing that you'd rather critique or
analyze a story rather than sit down and
write it out oh hang stop right there
okay I don't anymore because I get paid
so much more for actually writing well
how did that happen I guess because the
things I've been analyzing and thinking
about in teaching for 20 years a lot of
them have turned out to actually work
okay so so it's kind of nice you know
I've been talking about all the
seeing you know the structural tool and
all the core one was stuff but what it
turns out is they these things actually
do help and even though it's helped
other writers and I've been told that
for a long time it's great and a relief
that it they actually work so what I
find as a as a writer as opposed to
teacher is these tools work but so it's
a relief to have them so when I'm in
from stymied or I can't move forward I
go back to my own work I go back to my
own book I go back to my own lectures
then I go okay where am I like I'm
working on a miniseries now about Jack
Johnson who was the first
african-american heavyweight champion
boxing chapter in the US and it's it's
been sold a production company and but
they want they want changes on
co-writing it with a brilliant guy that
I met actually at a talk I gave and I
often meet people that I collaborate
with well when I give a talk and he had
this project and it was marvelous but
one of the things I talk about is the
superhero a model because you know
superheroes are big now right whether
they're serious like some of the of the
serious stories or if they're if they're
a comic like in Deadpool 2 we can talk
about that too
but the superhero is huge now and so the
superhero model involves a very
particular tool we can talk about at
some point I know if when I go into it
now but what I decided was because
several people would take
pass it at Jack Johnson and I think
someone actually making movie I'm not
very big but and I don't think I'm
giving away anything here secrets wise a
superhero the reason a superhero is fun
to watch is not for the same reason most
heroes are fun to watch most heroes are
fun to watch because they're wounded and
they've got some big bleeding wound and
and we're gonna watch them heal it
we're gonna watch that's the story
superheroes know superheroes are not
wounded they're superheroes often the
old-fashioned superhero the in 300 li
unless acts nitrous 300 leonidas he
doesn't have a wound it's like old my
mom he hurt me and I gotta figure out
how to do that no in 300 he's an
old-fashioned superior because all the
reason we want to watch an old-fashioned
cpu's to see if he can lift the bigger
weight that the villains putting on him
at the four crucial points of the story
the villain just gets bigger and says
hey yeah you could lift that three
hundred pounds huh think of the villain
and a superhero as a deranged trainer at
Gold's Gym and and you he's alright so
you're gonna lift 300 pounds right or
you did that okay so at the 30 page
point you lifted the 300 pounds okay 60
page point we're gonna put 900 pounds on
there can you lift that so the superhero
secret of a superhero story that kind of
superstore there's several kinds is that
can he lift the bigger weight the
villains put on that rack that's it
it's not about psychology it's not about
core levels so that was our job with
Jack Johnson how can the villain get
bigger on at the end of each episode
what's the bigger weight they could put
on Jack Johnson now instead of spending
weeks and months figuring out how is he
wounded how are we gonna give him a
mentors on one side woman whose only
other no no it's all about how big as
that villain is that feeling getting
bigger because if the villains getting
bigger the audience is gonna watch
Shakespeare did the same thing by the
way and I used to direct Shakespeare in
New York when I
was after school and Shakespeare had
wrestling matches in which the villain
just got bigger and bigger so in other
words long story short not anymore but I
really can use my tools to solve story
problems that I'm getting paid to solve
so when they work I'm so excited I'm so
ecstatic it means all the 20 years I've
spent doing this is actually paying off
for me and also now I have a little bit
more credibility and when I teach right
because the rap on teachers as well you
can teach what you can't do right yeah
that's what you're teaching you're not
doing okay I get it
well now I'm doing so I can say okay
well yeah give it these tools actually
do work so shut up shut up
i I I did it nanny Annie
[Laughter]
you